a quick video about what is it I
actually do so I work within a
recruitment industry and I work as a
recruitment consultant now what the hell
does a recruitment consultant actually
do now let me tell you it's loads
absolutely loads there's a common
misperception out there that recruiters
will loads of cash quick they'll always
be taken at their clients for fancy
dinners they're always attending
networking events drinking loads of
alcohol now we do do some of that but
there's so much that goes behind the
scenes that recruiters don't always
share or whatever and I think that's why
it's important that I wanted to share
this on this video so look the nuts and
bolts of it is business owners will pay
us recruitment consultants to find them
the right people that's how we earn our
money okay now what goes into finding
the right people is the toughest part
now a lot of people also with the
misperception is that we probably simply
as recruiters post a job advert on
LinkedIn a job advert on online job
boards and let the candidates come to us
now this couldn't be further from the
truth I've been in recruitment now for
going towards two and a half years and
I've never placed a candidate who's
applied for my job directly it just it
just doesn't happen in my opinion anyway
so we have to be proactive with the
tools that we have at our fingertips so
it's our database it's our own
individual networks it's using the
online job boards and some of the
Seavey's that we can find using LinkedIn
and the best recruiters will maximize
all of those tools the best it really is
how you use them so the first thing is
that that's what's gone on behind the
scenes we spend hours each day trying to
find the right people leaving voicemails
sending emails text messages spending
the late nights in the office all to
speak to the right people now what do we
also do we manage
was expectations that would be the
business owners and what they're looking
to pay what they can get in the market
and also candidates what can they
achieve what's realistic what isn't so
with that as well is we help throughout
the process so it's not a similar to
funding like people get over this it's
all done and dusted it's coaching the
client throughout in terms of what are
the motivation for the cabinet's there
that they're speaking to make sure
they're getting those things sort of
across candidates preparing them for the
interview go through that with them what
they shouldn't say what they should say
and then also a huge part of it when it
gets to the latter end of the stages is
basically making sure that both parties
are happy and that's the candidate and
the client the Kanaks happen with what's
on offer and the clients happy with what
they're offering suit to the candidate
is worth it's in their budget so you
have to manage expectations throughout
that process and then also you have to
negotiate you have to negotiate and the
client's behalf they have to negotiate
on the candidates behalf again to make
sure that both parties are happy now
there's so much that goes into being a
recruitment consultant and that's what
makes it so addictive and so fulfilling
when you have a client or a candidate
who calls you or send your mission goes
you know what you've done amazing there
you've happen to get an amazing job or
you've happen to get the perfect person
that's what it's all about so what
recruitment consultants don't do is put
their feet up and let the candidates
come to us trip loads of beer and loads
of money in the first six months no
there's so much hard work that goes into
it and that's why it's one of the best
jobs out there nothing more people
should be considering working in
recruitment
[Music]